sur un air des beatles voici la nouvelle
affiche que les habitants de guyancourt
vont pouvoir découvrir dans leur ville
un bout chez une fleuriste ou encore un
boulanger ils ont tous le sourire pour
une opération de communication qui vise
à les mettre en avant
les habitants disent marquée de commerce
de proximité et être en concurrence avec
ses grandes surfaces
donc là la ville a décidé de communiquer
communiquer et de mettre aussi en valeur
ces petites structures qui sont dans nos
centres vivre à guyancourt 140 commerces
de proximité sont présents sur
l'ensemble de la ville un chiffre
important pour vingt-huit mille
habitants et qui prouve que les petits
commerçants résiste face aux grandes
enseignes
c'est le cas de ce pressing qui profite
des nouvelles constructions de logements
et de la présence des entreprises à
proximité
la clientèle et je dirais c'est
essentiellement des jeunes qui dépendent
beaucoup du technocentre qui est à côté
ça fait tourner la maison d'après ça
fait tourner la boulangerie dirait on
les connaît tous et une petite famille
situation différente en revanche à
quelques mètres de là au centre ville
les problèmes de stationnement sont
pointés du doigt par les commerçants
aujourd'hui on n'a que trois places de
parking pour quatre commerces pour
quelques averses quand je dis quatre
commerces et boulangeries pharmacies
coiffure boucherie
je parle pas du détroit restaurant je
parle pas de deux voiles alors ils vont
vous dire on en a fait derrière l'église
sauf que pour aller derrière l'église
faut faire le tour complet selon un
récent rapport remis au gouvernement le
taux de vacance commercial toucherait 10
% des commerces de centre ville à
guyancourt ce taux ne dépasse pas les 7
%